Chiara is with us in Montgomery Alabama
hi Chiara how are you better than I
deserve what's up okay so I'm coming
well I'm calling in to get advice on
buying a house I was wondering if it is
smarter for me and my husband to rent
out or kabob one and I just want to tell
you a little bit of my situation before
you give me advice so the 24 years old
he just graduated in December from
college and he has 45 thousand dollars
in student loan debt and I had fourteen
thousand and what happened was we were
living rent-free in a house and my
grandmother lives
my mom and my auntie we had we were
living in a house for two years we got
married in college so that was always
you able to get married was a free house
anyway we had a baby I was on bed rest
for a couple months and we only had like
just enough money for a closing cost on
buying this house but anyway I'm sorry I
left out a huge part so my auntie she's
not in a hard place and suddenly she's
asked if we could you know move out so
she goes in the house because she's
homeless and so we didn't have money to
say we'd not time to say what to you
know prepare for that so I was just
trying to get your advice on it you need
to rent you're broke you have student
loan debt coming out your ears and you
need to rent until you get that cleaned
up and rent the cheapest possible thing
what's your household income like 16
that's both of you now have your big big
boy big girl jobs right yeah okay but
the issue is to rent okay like if we
okay so this house no issue is you're
broke you don't need to be buying a
house you're gonna make a mistake buying
a house when you're broken deeply in
debt the house is going to be a curse
rather than a blessing I want you to own
a home I don't want the home to own you
and so you guys need to clean up your
student loan debt live in something as
cheap as you can possibly live and clean
up all of your debts be debt-free build
your emergency fund with three to six
months of expenses and then save a good
strong downpayment and tall I started
talking about buying a house and don't
buy a house where the payment is more
than 1/4 of your take-home pay on a
15-year fixed but you've got two years
before you're ready to buy a house right
now okay that's okay
let me just say one more thing okay cuz
I just want it complete clarity so okay
so to find
together you know I did your 35% you
know how you said you should spend 35
percent of what you know more than that
on living expenses so yeah there are 35
percent and I say that right no I didn't
say sorry okay I'm sorry
that's right okay so to rent okay when
you look at the area we live in to rent
a place to stay in a decent area is at
least 750 and this house know is 500
you're not buying a house honey okay
you're broke okay okay and you can't you
you know if you're if you're buying a
house for 550 the exact same house would
rent for more because that's how real
estate works but that doesn't mean you
need to buy a house right now
you are deeply in debt and you have a
mess and you guys need to clean up your
mess and buy a house from a solid
position so no I would I would not do
that your auntie need you to move you
need to go get you a little apartment
somewhere and you guys need to do this
on a solid footing you're gonna mess up
if you don't listen to me this is going
to come back and bite you in the butt
kiddo but I'm not sure I won this
but that's okay if I didn't share a
decision you you're 24 years old you get
to make decisions but you called nice my
opinion and I was not unclear I've done
this a long long time I want you to own
a house I want you to be blessed with
homeownership as a part of your wealth
building plan and there's a safety
mechanism and a stability mechanism for
your family I want all of those things
for you I do not want that house to be a
curse to you when broke people buy
houses it makes them broker that's why
we call them mortgage brokers that's
where that comes from not really but
it's good job